Her low freak bitches.
You're doing something right now with this whole,
don't be a do nothing bitch thing.
Dot.
Are you aware of like how big this movement in?
I probably tweeted about it the other day that I was out,
I forget where I was,
but these two girls were arguing about the merits,
pros and cons of being a do nothing bitch.
And it was completely,
it was all after your fight and it was completely brought on by you.
Like some girls were like,
well listen,
you know like I don't like to fucking work.
You know,
I don't,
I don't want to know what's wrong with being a do nothing bitch.
And the other girl was like,
no,
she's fucking right.
You know,
like too many girls are out there and do contribute nothing to society like you
are.
All you do is consume.
If you are a do nothing bitch,
all you do is spend somebody else's money and try to look pretty.
Like that's all you do is you use stuff up,
you use up resources and you give nothing.
And so you're a pretty much a drain on society.
That's what I think they,
they don't think it that way.
They think what they are is something that all of these men want to fuck low.
So in,
in working really hard to attain this,
this appearance and all these men want to fuck that.
Uh,
what they are,
they've,
they've created capital.
They've created like a need for this brought up to think that it wasn't your
mission in life to be happy.
It was your mission in life to leave the world better than how you found it.
And by being a comeback at,
you're not going to do that.
It's not your mission in life.
That I love that.
Like introducing
like,
yes,
I invented that.
No,
I did it.
That's a fascinating thing to say that it's not your mission in life to be
happy.
So,
but what's the point in leaving the world better if no one's happy,
if everybody follows that same principle,
the world just keeps getting better and better and everybody's miserable as
fuck.
He doesn't seem to make sense here.
Your happiness is supposed to be a byproduct of actually living a fulfilling
life.
You know,
instead of just trying to,
you know,
if I tried to get drunk and party every day and get as happy as I possibly could
every day,
you know,
I'm going to live at a really unfulfilling life and die unhappy.
This isn't,
this is not like a micro aggression.
This is human curiosity had something that's abnormal.
Yeah.
It's not a bad thing that it's abnormal.
It's not that there's a gender issue that you wish you were a woman,
man,
are you wish you were a man or you're born a woman.
It's not a bad thing.
It's just,
it is.
There is a difference though.
And I think that we,
what we're experiencing now with the transgender movement and even to an extent,
the gay movement is the pendulum swinging all the way in one direction.
And it's a,
it's a reaction to the fact that,
and this is just a fact,
when you were a man or a woman and you felt overwhelmingly like you are a
different sex and you took measures to correct your current sex or you just
dressed up in a way that made you feel more yourself.
So if you're a man and you're dressed in drag or whatever,
as a woman or for that matter,
if you were gay and started having feelings when you include the,
the problem was that in most of our history,
you got the fucking shit kicked out of you,
killed your job,
got ostracized and that anger and that,
that injustice doesn't,
doesn't go away.
And so you have a lot of people that have that,
that memory is very fresh.
That wound is very real.
So let's have some fake pronouns the way that,
the way,
the way that is.
Then the,
then,
uh,
try to,
control the majority of the population's behavior.
What about I don't hear z h I like that they have those z.
It's one of them.
I know.
I was in,
I listened.
I went to high school in Massachusetts.
I remember when I knew when I had to,
when I had to say,
I couldn't say freshmen,
I had to say fresh person.
I dated a girl who graduated from Wellesley college with a degree in women's
studies,
women's studies.
It's all about women.
Yeah,
I know.
It's wonderful.
I should shave her legs.
There was a white girl I suffered.
I dated a white girl and she didn't share her legs.
Yeah.
It's very European.
No,
it's pretty hippie bro.
That's it.
It's nothing to do with European me.
That's fine.
But her,
her roommate was Greek.
I got in trouble.
Guess what?
Her feet looked like Bilbo Baggins women are hot though.
Hairy feet,
bro.
Shit,
here he toes hairy feet.
This was the girl you were with?
Nope.
The other girl,
her,
her roommate.
When you're a younger man,
you'll fuck a bear.
It does.
I mean,
I'm a go.
She was beautiful,
but she was blonde like,
oh,
she's a pretty girl.
And uh,
the,
uh,
the roommate there was a girl I dated who was liberal white girl.
Oh,
that's not real.
There was this white girl and she majored in African studies in college.
And I went and all I did was this.
I go,
why?
Because I knew the answer was she was a liberal white girl and just wanted other
black people.
It'd be like,
you're my favorite white.
You're my favorite white.
And you understand us and your town with our,
cause.
I know it wasn't because she was interested in African studies and then I said,
because I said,
why?
Why,
What about,
why did you choose to study African studies?
Not that there's anything wrong with it and not say what you come from,
like European history.
Why would you care what she's telling you?
I just wanted to know the answer.
Okay.
And what was her answer?
She said her answer was,
I wish she wasn't even in the black guys.
She goes,
uh,
I find that question offensive.
And I said,
Whoa,
that's what I thought you'd say.
It was really man,
really funny.
It's like you always see gangsters on TV,
but when you are confronted by true psychopaths,
it is unbelievable.
You know?
I,
uh,
well I told the story with Jerry one son,
his community and coffee,
but I didn't hear it.
Okay,
I got it.
I got a call one day from a Sinatra,
he says,
[inaudible] sons of Italy dinner in Italy.
Can,
can you do it one it,
it gives me the day.
And I said,
oh,
Mrs Sinatra,
I'm at the holiday house in Pennsylvania with the sons of the pioneers.
That's what the old,
I said,
I'm opening for them on that day.
I'd love to do it for you,
but I can't do it.
Oh,
okay.
Thanks.
I said a police,
any of
couple of hours later,
I get a call from Sinatra's agent.
Uh,
hey,
we call it a holiday house.
They said they don't need you.
I don't need Ya.
All right.
Guess I'm going to Chicago.
So I got to Chicago and it's this Italian,
I'm not going to use any real names because if people are still around,
so it's doing this thing instead of golf course.
And they say to me,
listen,
there's a priest here.
Okay,
so keep your act,
you know,
clean it.
Then I said to me,
okay fine.
So I got up on,
I do my little act to find.
Thank you.
Applause,
applause to sit down.
So this gangster guy gets up,
you know,
he goes on a welcome Y'alls tourists,
uh,
you notice this place and it wasn't going to say,
Oh shit,
I forgot.
I was going to say,
and what?
He said,
Shit.
The priests went
like this.
The guy goes,
wow,
hey father,
you've got your 10 grand on a fucking bag.
Shut off.
It just goes crazy on his gut and the places just,
everybody's just,
just frozen with Thea.
This guy,
he's just like crazy.
And the priest was like,
he's holding this bag with the 10 grand.
Did he know?
And then he sits now.
So when I'm sitting in the guy,
come late,
Jay,
come here.
He goes,
let me ask you something.
You know stone,
right?
I said,
why don't know him that you rocky just come out.
This is 1976 at me.
I said,
I don't know him.
I mean,
I met him,
you know,
we ask them to do this dinner,
this benefit today.
He said,
no.
And I said,
well,
I mean,
maybe he was busy
Fridays.
Quit screaming at me.
I go,
you're right,
I'm sure.
But yeah,
I'm fine.
He goes to,
he goes up,
this is,
come on,
let's play some golf.
I played golf.
I don't play golf.
I can look it up.
She's an hour in golf carts and my boy in this golf cart,
we drive out to about the 12th hole and we get to the 12th hole and there are
these kind of 50 60 year old prostitutes topless with leopard skin print,
mini skirts,
handing out drinks.
It was like the craziest day of my life.
But this guy was like a true psycho criminal.
I mean,
just one of those guys like a scene from Goodfellas.
It just kill it.
You know,
I always loved movies where somebody threatened someone and they go,
you're not going to kill me by,
because I know you're not the kind of guy.
No,
no.
They will kill you.
And they've just really made me laugh.
Is that guy still alive?
Uh,
I,
he may still be alive.
Really?
Nah,
this is a while ago.
He's probably dead by now because he was an old guy then.
Yeah,
it seems like a guy like that.
It's not going to make it.
I'll tell you.
I'll tell you his name.
No,
he made it through the teammates.
Wow.
Just hilarious.
Yeah.